I think it's a man's responsibility to
manage and lead the relationship and set
boundaries don't you don't you want to
be led in a relationship by a strong
man yeah my husband does that and it's
the best
thing so why I gonna the ownership
mentality why is that
good uh for me it gives me a chance to
be more of actual just a woman um and to
me that's being being able to be have
the space to be
carefree soft and me being a woman also
be able is able to give him the frame
that he wants and gives him A Home of
Peace and calmness as well just you know
just to State the obvious here in case
nobody's notice that Jessica is the one
that's actually married in a long-term
relationship sorry common law and the
other three girls are single so I'm
wondering if maybe it's worthwhile
listening to a few things that je
Jessica has to offer here now I don't
disagree with anything Jessica said
great now George said something there
was some issue with um what was it
ownership you said the ownership
mentality yeah the ownership of of me I
don't think it's an ownership thing I
think it's more of a leading
thing right like I don't own my girl
like she chooses to be with
me right but I still lead the
relationship and I set boundaries around
it because I'm a man and that's what I'm
supposed to do
gu your boundaries are your
responsibility what's that Kenzie your
boundaries are your
responsibility I don't have to change I
don't have to change who I am to fit
your boundaries if I yeah you can go
don't fit your boundaries yeah exactly
it's like it's it's all about in my
opinion it's all about compromise and
discussion there's it's I don't have to
change I am to fit your boundaries if
these are your boundaries and they can't
change then like then it is what it is
I'm not your person you're not my person
like yeah and you go no it's absolutely
right and you would be left behind like
if I was dating and you know the way
that I would recommend guys to do that
is they they should date a bunch of
women non monogamously
simultaneously uh until the cream Rises
at the top and one of the girls are two
of the girls or something like that says
hey Rich I dig your Vibe I don't want to
share you I'm not seeing anybody else
Where Do We Stand what are we building
here then that's when I would take a
look at her life and I'd be like Oh okay
that's interesting right and then I
would contemplate maybe if I wanted to
get into an LTR with you this isn't a
conversation that we' that we'd have
early on Kenzie like if we're dating
yeah this wouldn't even come up it's
only when you want to claim me then I'm
going to take a look at your life and
I'm be like well hang on a second I mean
I can't take a girl seriously that that
that like goes out to dinner with
ex-boyfriends and you know keeps a bunch
of guys around in her life like that's
just not a gal that I could take
seriously right and it's like then it's
on you do you want to make a decision to
keep doing that or do you want to leave
those guys behind because you see me as
high enough value that you want to move
into my world right
it's as simple as that like this is how
I have guys lead relationships and women
and not all women are going to want to
do that maybe they're not going to see
the guy's high enough value maybe they
don't like them enough maybe they don't
have genuine burning desire it's any
number of things that can get in the way
maybe their mind's just polluted with
toxic feminism I don't know but it
doesn't matter because when I tell guys
to do these things it's to enforce good
boundaries in the relation like it's for
the betterment of the relationship and
as Jessica just Illustrated it's it's
good for the relationship it's it's
better to be led
um I can't tell you how many women I've
I've talked to they're
like got like for example Jillian and
Jordan okay so you roast dudes because
of what they say I'm assuming that
you've come across guys that are like
they can't decide where when to pick you
up where you're gonna date what time
you're gonna meet where you're gonna
meet right these types of guys yeah okay
so guys like this like I'm guessing that
these are the guys that you're
roasting no you're not sometimes they're
they'll come off the bat and just be
like overtly sexual or just odd and you
know but I think like that kind of plays
into boundaries and standards that we're
holding as well like I think both men
and women like I do agree with you I
mean I agree it is a man's role to lead
in a relationship right but I think go
which goes beyond just picking the
restaurant and picking you up and stuff
like that like it goes into eras like I
can't deal with a woman on a long-term
basis that hangs out with guys right
like that like that is The Next Step
Beyond we're going to meet at 8:00 and
we're going to go to this place and you
know meet for our first date sort of
thing I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out